систем не золя кого не кримських татар
ціни не найбільші попович кримської
правозахисниці змаже 20-річним стажем
лілію gemy g як приклад wanna раз
побач оправи за духом бахчисараї студії
у пляшках кримських татар там
етнографічному кафе посилань проблема
самі оптикою люди вийшли на волоссі
просто Петро їм це своїх сусідів
вас плакати і гасли човник цим очі у
кованого криму до сезону і взагалі їх у
для un несанкціонованого мітингу та
тяга я з повістками у посудах якщо
боротися як що ви пологів і просто прийшли
на процес вас взуття крізь нього темрява
комару це за образ перерубати знайти
поліції та фсб число у quake геть з рубля
мету відкрито у вас знімають і на східну
двору те досьє
2 адміністративних покарання та доступний
коло кримінальні за таку схему з міста
і по стежки там уже шкіряни нині 43
політичних я зніму криму 23 кримські
татари на думку медійну і несе її в
виправлю димиться стрибав від овочі влада
окупованого пиво острова золя Кайра
сам парад корінне населення
адже терористів та екстремістів до
організатори вносилися очі про план
влада в Росії на рахунки потрібна і менше
двом кримським татарам змінив і ланку
vaccine
ти пар влада можеш енрік продовжив це
розслідування в 2 чого не сідаючи у сізо
у ван ібн їх умовах ви на ціні ви руку
витягуєте він же і годину подачі з них
справно ростверк європейського суду
справа видно і а тобто все тут коли
підлога і праворуч пройдуть усі стадії тугим і
по хатах я спати чаєм однозначно все і
справа всяких я в знак і порушення
конвенції про страви будуть у
європейському суді
думаю проспекті увійти десятки та десятки
справа вже то парту ти подав і бісять
праворуч і десятки робив та й ціна сам
парад про право до порушення і право на
свободу мирних зборів
я поведу мам адвокат на заради європейський
суд за роботу захід б Росії про це
чи поясні причини так їх забур він ще
правда процес комунікації права рука
ми пройшли що хвалити ви руки